you write more technology means better
good times but it also means bad or bad
times and the scary thing is if the good
and bad keep exponentially growing it
doesn't matter how great the good times
become if the bag gets to a certain
level of bad it's all over for us can
you elaborate on this why why is there
why does the bad have uh that property
that if it's all exponentially getting
more powerful then the bat is going to
win in the end was is my misinterpreting
that no so the first thing is I noticed
a trend
which was like
the centuries the good is getting better
every Century like the 20th century was
the best Century yet in terms of
prosperity in terms of GDP per capita in
terms of life expectancy in terms of
poverty and disease and every metric
that matters the 20th century was
incredible it also had the biggest Wars
in history the biggest genocide in
history the biggest existential threat
yet with nuclear weapons right you know
the Depression was you know probably as
big an economic so it's this interesting
thing where the stakes are getting
higher in both directions and so the
question is like if you get enough good
does that protect you against the bat
right the the the the dream and I do
think this is possible too is the good
gets so good you know have you ever read
the culture series The Ian Banks books
not yet but I get criticized on a daily
basis but some of the mutual folks we
know for not having done so lots and I
feel like a lesser man for it yes I need
so that that that's how I got onto it
and I read six of the ten books
um and they're great but the thing I
love about them is like it just paints
one of these
futuristic societies where the good has
has gotten so good that the bad is no
longer even an issue like basically and
the way that this this works is the AI
you know the AIS
um
are benevolent and they control
everything and so like there's one
random anecdote where they're like you
know what happens if you murder someone
in because he's still you know there's
still people with rage and jealousy or
whatever so so someone murdered someone
um first of all that person's backed up
so it's like they help to get a new body
and it's it's annoying but it's like
it's not death and secondly that person
what are they gonna do put them in jail
no no they're just going to send a slap
drone around which is this little like
tiny you know random drone that just
will float around next to them forever
and by the way kind of be their servants
like it's kind of fun to have a slap
drone but just making sure that they
never do anything and it's like I was
like oh man it could just be everyone
could be so safe and everything could be
so like you know you want a house you
know the as will build your house
there's endless space there's endless
resources so I do think that that could
be part of our future that's part of
what excites me is like there is like
today would seem like a utopian to
Thomas Jefferson right Thomas
Jefferson's world would seem like a
Utopia to a caveman
there is a future and by the way these
are happening faster these jumps right
so the thing that would seem like a
Utopia to us we could experience in our
own lifetimes right like it's especially
a female life extension it combines with
exponential progress
um I want to get there and I think if in
that part of what makes it Utopia is you
don't have to be as scared of the the
worst bad guy in the world trying to do
the worst damage because we have
protection
but that said
um I'm not sure how that happens like
it's it's
either easier said than done Nick
Bostrom uses the example of if nuclear
weapons could be manufactured by
microwaving sand for example
we'd probably be in the Stone Age right
now because
0.001 of people would love to destroy
all Humanity right some 16 year old with
huge mental health problems who right
now goes and shoots up a school would
say oh even better I'm going to blow up
a city and now suddenly there's copycats
right and so
that's like as our technology grows it's
going to be easier for the worst bad
guys
to do and tremendous damage and it's
easier to destroy than to build so it
takes a tiny tiny number of these people
with enough power to do bad so that to
me I'm like the stakes are going up
because the the what we have to lose is
this incredible Utopia but also like
dystopia is real it happens the Romans
ended up in a dystopia they've probably
earlier thought that was never possible
like
we should not get cocky and so to me
that that trend
is the exponential Tech is a
double-edged sword it's so exciting I'm
happy to be alive now overall because
I'm an optimist and I find it exciting
but it's really scary and we and and the
the the the the dumbest thing we can do
is not be scared dumbest thing we can do
is get cocky and think well my life is
always the last couple Generations
everything's been fine
stop that
what's Your Gut what percentage of
trajectories take us towards the as you
put unimaginably good future versus
unimaginably bad future
is it are you as an optimist it's really
hard to know I mean it all like you know
one of the things we can do is look at
history and
on one hand there's a lot of stories
actually listening to a great podcast
right now called the fall of
civilizations
um and it's literally every episode is
like you know a little like two hour
Deep dive into some civilization some
are really famous like the Roman Empire
some are more obscure like the the
Norris in Greenland but
um but it's each one is so interesting
but what's
it's I mean there's a lot of
civilizations that had their Peak
there's always the peak right when
they're thriving and they're they're Max
size and and and they have their
waterways and they have their civilized
and it's representative and it's fair
and whatever I'm not not always but it's
it's uh the peak is a great you know if
I could go back in time you know it's
not that you don't you know the farther
you go back the worse it gets no no you
want to go back to a civilization during
I would go to the Roman Empire in the
year 100. it sounds great right you
don't want to go to the Roman Empire in
the year 400. we might be in the peak
right now here whatever honestly I I
think about like the 80s you know the
70s the 80s Here We Go the music no no
it's so much better no the 80s culture
is so annoying it's just like I'm I'm
when I re when I listen to these things
I'm thinking you know the 80s and 90s
America the 90s was popular people
forget that now like Clinton was a
superstar around the world Michael
Jordan was exported internationally then
basketball was everywhere suddenly you
had like music the sports whatever it
was a little probably like the 50s you
know you're coming out of the World War
and the depression before it was like
this kind of like everyone was in a good
mood kind of time you know it's like a
finish a big project and it's Saturday
it was like I feel like the 50s was kind
of like everyone was having it you know
the the
um 20s I feel like everyone was in good
mood randomly
um then the the 30s everyone was in a
bad mood
um but the 90s I think we'll look back
on it as a time when everyone was in a
good mood and it was like you know again
of course at the time it doesn't feel
that way necessarily but I look at that
I'm like maybe that was kind of
America's Peak and like no maybe not but
like it hasn't been popular since really
worldwide um it's gone in and out
depending on the country but like it
hasn't reached that level of like
America's awesome around the world and
the political you know situations gotten
you know really ugly and you know maybe
it's social media maybe who knows but I
I wonder if it'll ever be a simple
and and positive as it was then like
maybe we are in the in the you know it
feels a little like maybe we're in the
beginning of the downfall or not because
because these things don't just go it's
not a perfect smooth Hill it goes up and
down and up and down so maybe we're
there's another big upcoming and it's
unclear whether public opinion which is
kind of what you're talking to is uh
correlated strongly with influence as
you could say that even though America's
been on a decline in terms of public
opinion the exporting of Technology
that America has still with all the talk
of China has still been leading the way
in terms of AI in terms of social media
in terms of just basically any software
related product like chips yeah chips so
hardware and software I mean America
leads the way you could argue that
Google and Microsoft and Facebook are no
longer American companies they're
International companies but they really
are still at the you know headquarters
in Silicon Valley broadly speaking so uh
in Tesla of course and just all of its
all the technological innovation still
seems to be happening in the in the
United States although culturally
and politically
it this is not it's not it's not good
well maybe that could shift at any
moment when all the technological
development can actually be
create some positive impact in the world
yeah that can shift it with the right
leadership and so on with the right
messaging
yeah I I think um
I I don't feel confident at all about
whether no no I don't mean that I don't
mean I don't feel confident in my
opinion that we may be on the downswing
or that we may be like I truly don't
know it's like I think the people
these are really big macro stories that
are really hard to see when you're
inside of them it's like it's like being
on a beach and and running around you
know a few miles this way I've been
trying to suss out the shape of the
coastline like it's just really hard to
see the big picture you know you get
caught up in the the the micro Stories
the little tiny you know ups and downs
that are part of some bigger Trend and
and also giant Paradigm shifts happen
quickly nowadays the internet you know
came out of nowhere and suddenly was
like
you know change everything so there
could be a changed everything thing on
the way it seems like there's a few
candidates for it and like but but I
mean it feels like the stakes are just
High it higher than it even was for the
Romans higher than it was for because
um that we we're more powerful as a
species we have god-like powers with
technology that other civilizations at
their Peak didn't have and so I I wonder
if those high stakes and Powers will
feel laughable to people that live
humans aliens cyborgs whatever lives 100
years from now
that maybe maybe are a little like this
feeling of political and technological
turmoil is is nothing well that's the
big question you could EAS so right now
you know you know the 1890s was like a
super politically contentious decade in
the U.S it was like immense tribalism
um and the newspapers were all like
lying and telling you know you know
there was a lot of like what we would
associate with today's media the worst
of it
um and it was over gold or silver being
this I don't know it was very it's
something that I don't understand but
the point is it was a little bit of a
blip right it happened it felt it must
have felt like the end of days at the
time and then now we most people don't
even know about that uh versus you know
again the Roman Empire actually
collapsed and so the the question is
just like is yeah you know will in 50
years will this be like or like
McCarthyism oh they had like uh oh that
was like a crazy few years in America
and then it was fine
um or is this the beginning of something
really big and then that's what
well I wonder if we can predict uh what
the big thing is at the beginning it
feels like we're not we're just here
along for the ride and at the local
level and at every level of trying to do
our best how do we do our best what's
the that's the one thing I know for sure
is that we need to have our wits about
us and do our best and the way that we
can do that you know we have to be as
why is this possible Right to proceed
forward and wisdom ever is an emergent
property of discourse so your proponent
of wisdom versus stupidity because you
can make an uh uh I can still man the
case for stupidity
do it I probably can't but there's some
I think wisdom and you talk about this
can come with a false confidence
arrogance I mean you talk about this in
the book that's too easy that's not
wisdom then if you're being arrogant
you're being unwise unwise yeah you know
I think I think wisdom is doing what
people a hundred years from now with the
hindsight that we don't have would do if
they could come back in time and they
knew everything it's like how do we
figure out how to have hindsight when we
actually or not what if stupidity is the
thing that people from 100 years from
now will see us wise
being naive and uh trusting everybody
maybe that well then you get lucky then
then you you know that then maybe you
get to a good a good future by stumbling
upon it
um but ideally you you can get there
like I think a lot of we the America the
great things about it are a product of
the wisdom of previous Americans you
know the Constitution was a pretty you
know pretty wise system to set up
there's not much stupid stumbling around
well there is I mean with deceas uh the
idiot Prince Michigan and uh Brothers
karmazov there's uh uh aliosha you err
on the side
of love
and almost like a naive trust in other
human beings and that turns out to be at
least in my perspective and long term
for the success of the species is
actually wisdom it's a compass we don't
know it's because you're in the fog in
the fog it's a compass yeah
love is a compass okay but but here's
the thing so I think we should have a
compass is nice but you know what else
is nice is a flashlight in the fog that
can help you can't see that far but you
can see oh you can see four feet ahead
instead of one foot and that to me is
discourse that is open vigorous like
discussion in a culture that Fosters
that is how the species is how the the
the the the American citizens as a unit
can be
as wise as possible can maybe see four
feet ahead instead of one foot ahead
that said uh Charles Bukowski said that
love is a fog that Fades with the first
light of reality so I don't know how
that works out but I feel like there's
intermixing of metaphors that works